and finally in the sun's point about the
global media will this big problem here
really which is impart to do with the
way the world of the media works because
you know it's what I actually call the
tyranny of the protest you know if
you've got a public meeting and you got
a thousand people there and five people
jump up and shout and throw things
there's and I know okay you know those
five people would take the news that
night the other 995 might as well know
exists it's it's it's a problem it's a
real problem this and what we need to do
is to you know it's like you know I just
know that debates in the in the newsroom
right if you're debating something like
ground zero someone who comes out and
says look I think this is all very
difficult you know I can see we've got
to be fair but I think it needs to be
done in the right way we're going to
approach it very carefully some person
comes out and says this is an outrage
right they've got you know they're there
they're through the door you know this
shows the Muslims trying to take over
America right there through the door you
know is it's a this shows that the very
fact you're having this debate shows
that the West hates Islam I mean one of
the things that was interesting about
that whole Pastor Jones and learning the
crime business and it's a very important
thing actually about what's going on in
the world is there in two important
things about it one is that he was
trying to do it but most people said he
shouldn't right but the second thing is
the fact that virtually every Western
leader including President Obama had to
come out and denounce him because
actually
some crazy man someplace in Pakistan who
burns a Bible we wouldn't expect them to
have to come out and do that you
wouldn't this is interesting this in
many different ways it's interesting
because it is actually a one-level
absurd to say but people were saying and
could get on the news saying this shows
the disrespect in which the West holds
Islam which is in a sense ridiculous
because he's a pastor with 50 or is it
now 20 people his church I mean it's but
the fact that it became a worldwide
phenomenon shows the very I mean it
shows actually the relevance of what
we're talking about here and the trouble
is this and this is why the patient work
that is about bringing people together
is got to be done more forcefully and a
lot deeper because it will not have the
same inflammable capacity to go and
dominate the news and that's what makes
it very difficult